you're wrong
c
so
hello
[Music]
much
come on
the thing
right now
you're killing two minute warning on the
press briefing
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
oh yeah
yes
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone
okay a couple things at the top mondays
there's always a lot to report
i'm sure you feel that way uh later
today
the president the first lady the vice
president and the second gentleman
will mark the solemn milestone of 500
000 american lives lost
to covet 19. they will ask all americans
to join in a moment of silence during a
candle lighting ceremony at sundown
president biden will also deliver
remarks and order all flags on federal
property
to be lowered at half-staff for the next
five days
tonight's events including the
president's remarks will highlight the
magnitude of loss
that this milestone marks for the
american people and so many families
across the country
he will also speak to the power of the
american people to turn the tide on this
pandemic by working together
following public health guidelines and
getting in line to be vaccinated as soon
as they are eligible
as you all know there are a number of
confirmation hearings coming up
this week uh almost half a million
americans and as we
look at these we're looking at through
the prism of the fact that almost half a
million americans as i just noted
have lost their lives to this cool
pandemic tens of millions
have lost their jobs families can't put
enough food on the table
and millions of children need their
schools reopened
and central to the all hands on deck
response we're executing from the biden
harris administration
is having qualified experienced and
groundbreaking nominees installed as
quickly as possible
and we want to thank of course the
senate for the steps they are taking
they have taken i should say over the
last few weeks to support and confirm
often with a large bipartisan votes many
of our nominees
but underlining our pressing need to
have our team in place
we have of course merrick garland who is
currently doing his hearing right now
he's been endorsed by multiple former
republican attorneys general
as someone faithful to the law and not
politics and who multiple republican
senators agree is a
political come would come to the job
with decades of experience
javier becerra attorney general javier
percera
who helped play a role in getting the
affordable care act
through and has brings decades of
healthcare policy experience to the
table
as attorney general of california he
fought alongside his republican
counterparts to expand access to covid
treatments
near a tandon a brilliant policy expert
with experience the highest levels of
government also running
a big think tank in washington dc who
understands firsthand the power
of policy and helping families gain a
foothold in the middle class
it was a wide spectrum of support
ranging from the chamber of commerce to
labor unions
miguel cardona public school teacher
former public school teacher who will
champion and help
expedite the reopening of our schools
that will be his first priority we're
eager to see him in place
and congresswoman marcia fudge who
served as mayor and will be
has formerly served as a mayor and will
be invaluable as both parties work to
protect families from losing their homes
during the covid outbreak as you know
many of you saw the president just made
an announcement
this morning about important changes to
the ppp program
to ensure small businesses especially
minority owned and mom-and-pop
businesses get the help they need to
keep their doors open
and keep workers on payroll 98
of companies have fewer than 20
employees and a big part of this
announcement will apply to those
companies
these small businesses employ nearly
half of america's worst
and account for 44 our nation's gdp
more than 400 000 small businesses have
permanently shuttered due to the panic
millions more have lost substantial
value so revenue so
clearly an area where there is a need
great focus
his announcement includes instituting a
two-week window starting wednesday
during only businesses with fewer than
20 employees so
90 90 of them uh can apply for relief
through the program
so they that we prioritize support to
businesses who are previously left
behind
the changes also uh include expanding
eligibility so that sole proprietors
independent contractors and
self-employed americans as well as
immigrants who are lawful permanent
residents can receive
more support and finally the changes
announced today will roll back
restrictions that disproportionately
impacted entrepreneurs of color
from receiving relief including
americans who are behind on student loan
payments
and business owners who were formally
incarcerated for non-fraud
convictions i also just had an update on
the winter storm
on friday the president approved a major
disaster
declaration as many of you know for the
state of texas including public and
hazard mitigation assistance for all 254
texas counties in that declaration 77
texas counties were approved for
individual assistance
which allows for uninsured property
owners to seek federal assistance if
their home is damaged
by burst pipes caused from freezing
weather more counties will likely we
expect more counties to be added as more
work is done to evaluate need and that's
a reflection of fema's
initial evaluation in the meantime the
president has asked fema
to do everything it can to rapidly
distribute aid to the state of texas
so far more than 1 million meals have
been shipped to texas more than 4
million liters of water have been
shipped to texas the department
of defense fixed wing aircraft continue
to
deliver water and bulk to multiple
locations in texas
they've completed nine missions so far
with an additional 10 missions planned
for today
69 emergency generators and more than a
hundred and twenty thousand blankets
have been
delivered to texas and over the weekend
uh
homeland security advisor liz sherwood
randall national economic council
director ryan dees
governor abbott update him on the broad
federal effort the president has
requested to support
citizens of the state coping with the
impact of the storm
and of course the recovery from here uh
last but not least where's debra
saunders she's in the back oh there she
is okay so i'm gonna
uh this i want to take a moment to
recognize that milestone in the briefing
room today is her last day in the print
pool and potentially
her last day in the briefing room
although you're of course welcome back
and even though she's leaving the white
house press corps
and full-time reporting i know she's
going to be writing some columns and i
have a feeling they'll be hearing from
her
um quite frequently so congratulations
on covering the white house for four
years as many of you know that
that is not for the faint of heart uh so
let's start with your questions
but i won't be your last yes that's
right that's that's fair
so i want to start with a housekeeping
question oh okay well
we'll just go to you it will go to you
go ahead thank you so much
um this morning i saw there was no
marine out front
in the front door during the 9 45
briefing and i asked lower press lower
press says
we don't have to have a running up front
when the president is in the oval office
and i've been getting emails and
questions ever since i filed that pool
report
is if there is if there was no marine
out front does that mean that the
president is not in the oval office
the president was in the oval office
this morning uh working receiving the
pdb and all the things that you're aware
of from the schedule
there hasn't been a change of policy
if there's no marine there that doesn't
mean anything
uh again i mean i could certainly talk
to them about the specific circumstances
of this morning but i can report to you
that the president was in the oval
office and
the policy that's long been in place uh
continues to be in place
people are fascinated by this i have two
questions about it okay
one does the president have a position
there's a bill in nevada to get rid of
the caucus and make it a primary
and there's a hope that nevada's going
to be first and that is going to be
first
so could you please tell me does the
president have a position on that
there's plenty of time for politics
president's been in office for a month
um i'd refer you to the dnc and others
who will uh
make lead that process moving forward
position on renaming mccarran after
harry reid
hello president is a big fan close
friend of harry reid uh worked with him
closely on
a number of important issues including
getting the affordable care act
through uh as i understand it it's
passed the local legislature i believe
and it's now
uh through or the local of where it
needs to pass locally i should say
um and it's now being considered by the
faa so i would refer you to them
one last question about about the way
washington looks right now
there are fences everywhere we have
national guard
what's president's view what's the
administration's view about how long
it's going to keep going on like this
and and why is why is it going to
continue it looks like
into march which piece are you referring
to
guard i'm talking about all the fences
that are around here
their fences around capitol hill i
understand
things happened on january 6. how much
lava do you think you're going to have
all the security
well i would i would look at those a
little bit separately because of course
members of congress leadership on the
hill democrats and republicans will make
decisions
about the security needed and we support
at the capitol and we certainly support
them in that decision-making process
as it relates to the fencing around of
the white house
you know we work of course closely with
the secret service the national park
service and the president
and the vice president are certainly uh
eager to have that brought down
uh at an appropriate time and hopefully
that's soon
all right joshua thanks guy two
questions
you touched on the issue of nominations
and confirmations
given the statements of senator manchin
senator collins senator romney
what do you see as nero tandon's path to
become director of lmb
and also what does it mean for the biden
agenda if this process
keeps on being delayed and girl now the
process of confirmations
well let me start with that i would say
that um we
experienced some intransigence uh during
that during the transition
some delays in processes that had
previously worked
at a more rapid pace our view is that
we've hopefully moved past that we've
seen a number of our
uh nominees uh move forward over the
past couple of weeks pretty quickly
with large bipartisan votes and we
certainly welcome that
but we are eager to have our team in
place this week has a number of
important
hearings there are a number of important
votes this week we would love to end the
week with a secretary of education
in place as an example and certainly
others as we
as we look to have the full team uh and
hopefully a full cabinet meeting
at some point in the near future as it
relates to nira tandon let me just say
that the president nominated her because
he believes she'd be
a stellar omb director she's tested
she's a leading policy expert she's led
a think tank
in this in washington that has done a
great deal of work on policy issues but
has done a great deal of bipartisan work
as well
she's won widespread support and
endorsements ranging from labor unions
to the u.s chamber of commerce and she's
rolled up her sleeves and done the work
she's met with more
more than 35 senators democrats and
republicans herself
this is a process confirmations getting
individuals confirmed as she has
two committee votes this week uh and
we're working toward that and we'll
continue to work in supporting her
nomination
votes or more we do then secondly
we've seen some issues with regard to
iran restricting access to nuclear
inspectors
and i was curious for how this works
with secretary of state lincoln
saying he expects strict compliance by
iran in order to re-enter the deal with
the united states
well first i think you're referring to
the reports from the iaea over the
weekend and kind of discussions
uh they had about iran's compliance and
access that they um would have or
were looking to have to iran's
facilities on the ground and certainly i
would subdue to them on that but i would
say that
uh what secretary blinkens and
announcement
and what our announcement that came out
last week
is a reflection of is an openness to
have a conversation
and openness to diplomacy and that
invitation was issued by the europeans
uh to invite us
to invite the iranians to the table to
have a conversation
we have indicated said no indication
that we are
willing to take additional steps in
advance of that what we're willing to do
is sit at a table and have a diplomatic
conversation uh because we are looking
uh
to uh to prevent iran from acquiring a
nuclear weapon and we believe diplomacy
is the best way to do that
uh let's go jeff just one follow-up on
iran uh iran's ayatollah said today that
iran may enrich uranium up to 60
purity if needed what is the white
house's reaction to that and how does
that impact
the statement that that you made last
week about openness to talks
well again jeff uh you know iran is a
long way from compliance and
that hasn't changed i said that last
week and many and i believe my
colleague national security advisor jake
sullivan conveyed that just yesterday
that has not changed
all what we are open to is a diplomatic
conversation
and our view is that diplomacy is the
best best path forward to preventing
iran from acquiring a nuclear weapon
uh that does not mean they have clearly
not taken the steps needed to comply
uh and we have not taken any steps or in
and made an indication that we are going
to meet the demands that they are
putting forward either does this kind of
rhetoric
concern you though in terms of the
possibility for diplomacy
uh well i think we're at the stage where
we're waiting uh the europeans are
waiting to hear uh iran's reply to their
invitation to have
a conversation so that's the stage we're
sitting at at this point in time
of diplomacy uh china's foreign minister
made some remarks
today about wanting to re sort of rejig
the relationship with the united states
and he
called for tariffs to be removed i know
that this policy is under review along
with lots of policies but can you give
any reaction to what he has said and any
update
on president biden's feelings about
tariffs and broader china policies
well you know i think as we said around
the time when the president
uh had a conversation with president xi
uh we
uh believe the relationship with china
is one of strong competition
uh we want to come to that relationship
from a position of strength that means
working in close coordination with our
partners and allies around the world
europeans other partners in the region
also with democrats and republicans
in congress and it also means we want to
do work at home
and focus on doing work at home to make
sure we are coming to that from a
position of strength as you noted uh
there's of course a review of our
tariffs um and the tariffs that were put
in place i don't have any update on that
at this point in time
you want to follow up on what josh asked
you about neura uh
camden you said that the white house
still sees a pathway
without senator manchin what is it
well again i think you know she needs
the majority of votes in order to get
through and be confirmed as the omb
director
that's what we're working toward
uh well i don't have a whip coat for you
here but we are certainly we take
nothing for granted
and part of our effort is not just
reaching out to republicans which we
certainly are doing and
all of our nominees do as well but also
ensuring that democrats who have
questions who have any concerns have
their questions answered too and we take
nothing for granted in
uh pushing forward with our nominees um
in opposing
republicans and at least one democrat
that said they expected more for the
president's nominees
in the vein of uniting a divided country
what's your response to that specific
criticism
that they have leveled that she spent
years stoking that divine
on the air and online well here's what i
can
convey and about her work as uh as
uh somebody who ran cap of the center
for american progress
uh she worked with partners across the
ideal ideological spectrum to
develop consensus solutions to
addressing the federal tax code
uh to improving access to high quality
educational opportunities they partnered
with aei in that effort
she worked with led the effort to work
with
freedomworks and others on the r street
institute on
making progress on criminal justice
reform and again she met with 35 members
of the senate uh including republicans
so
she is willing and eager to meet with
people who agree with her of course but
also people who disagree with her and
what she brings to the table is not only
decades of policy experience but
um an expertise and leadership again of
a
a major think tank in this uh city but
also somebody who
has lived experience you know she grew
up as the daughter of a
single mother somebody who benefited
from many of the programs that she would
be tasked with determining the the
recommendations on funding for
so uh she has a record of working with
members of both parties or
views from both parties uh and i we have
no doubt she would do that as a budget
the president director a little while
ago about it and noted that there are
some concerns
about the size of the price tag
would the white house be okay if it went
north of 1.9 trillion dollars for
whatever reason
well i think uh the president proposed
the 1.9 trillion dollar size because he
felt that was the
those were the components that were
needed to meet the moment we're facing
uh and uh certainly uh you know
he looks to congress to negotiate
through
what can be added or subtracted from
that package but
uh he has the had the key priority
components in it because that's what he
felt would be at the moment that's what
health and
economic experts were telling him but i
don't have anything
more for you beyond the beyond what he
proposed
specifically the hostages that they're
holding jake solomon said yesterday
we've begun to communicate with the
iranians on this issue
they later clarified it's not with
washington directly so can you just
clarify
is this being done through the swiss or
other european
officials instead we have a range of
means of uh
communicating uh with the iranians um
and uh we certainly raise uh american
citizens who are being held
uh in iran uh through those channels uh
but i don't have anything more specific
there's nothing direct going on as far
as you know to the united states
again we have a range of channels um
that we navigate or communicate through
direct and indirect but i don't have
anything more specific to lay out for
you
go ahead i'm just going to go pick out
what eddie was saying here sure the
president just said that uh
you sort of need to put them on
republican support he said critics
are saying that's too big what would you
have me cut what would you have me leave
out
what is he willing to cut is he willing
to leave out and what specifically
is the ball if they're gonna come to the
table and make some offers
what's negotiating we'll see what they
offer uh you know
what what has been offered uh to date uh
was a
proposal of about 600 billion dollars
which falls far
far short of what is needed at this
point in time with dual crises that the
country is facing
he was making the point and he did
something similar in his remarks on
friday
that uh you know this is a difficult
time the country is facing uh that's why
400 mayors have come out and said
they support this package that's why
democratic and republican
governors have come out and said that
business leaders others that's why the
majority of the american people support
it
so the point he's making he wasn't
offering a negotiation he was making the
point that
the key components of this bill are
addressing the crisis we're facing
so would you cut funding for schools
would only half of the schools that need
funding get funding
would only half of the people who uh are
uninsured are uh sorry
need uh uh you know deserve to direct
direct checks
should only half of them get them you
know the point he's making is that
um the size of the package is a
reflection of the size of the crisis
and you mentioned at the top of your
remarks the grim milestone that the
country is facing today with these 500
000 deaths
as the country is in this moment of
reflection a hundred thousand
of those americans have died within the
last month um
what reflections is this white house
having on on the last month um
as we ask as a country could more have
been done as dr frauchi said today
didn't have to be this bad
could more have been done in the last
month also well i think we
uh one inherited um a circumstance where
there was not
a there were not enough vaccines ordered
there were not enough vaccinators
available to vaccinate americans
and there were not enough places to uh
for people to go
to get those vaccines um shot into their
arms
and you know you can always look back
and say we wish we would have
done this better we wish the storm
wouldn't have come but our focus
is on building out of the hole that we
inherited
and ensuring that we are taking every
step necessary every step
possible to reach people in their
communities
to tap into the manufacturing sector
through the dpa
to communicate effectively about
eligibility
uh and that's that's what our focus is
in on at this point in time the path
forward
uh go ahead caitlin a few questions for
you one on the coveted relief bill
senator bernie sanders said he does
believe that the parliamentarian is
going to rule
that 15 minimum wage can be in there but
given two democrats have said they do
not want it in there and they don't want
to go forward if it's in there
if they rule that it can be in there
does president biden still want it
included
well the the president would not have
included an increase in the minimum wage
if he did not want to see it in the
final package
uh and certainly we are in close touch
with senator sanders and his team
and we hope that he's right and that it
is included in the package
uh but uh we'll see what the
parliamentarian says
at that process as you noted katelyn is
underway now
the birdbath as they call it my favorite
term of the week and
uh we'll see what comes out on the other
end and then
what it looks like for members of
congress and who have expressed support
or
or opposition to it they'll have to make
a decision at that point in time but
the stage we're at right now is it needs
to go through the parliamentary process
okay um
you talked about how you believe the
white house believes she is
qualified for this job you talk about
her past experience but the specific
criticisms that we're getting from these
people who are saying they are not going
to vote for her is that
mitt romney said he is critical of
extreme rhetoric susan collins says
she's demonstrated
exactly the kind of animosity president
biden pledged to transcend
manchin said he's worried that her
statements have a toxic and detrimental
impact on the working relationship
that they're expected to have with the
budget director so does the white house
believe that her past
statements are inflammatory well caitlyn
uh we would the president would not have
nominated her if he did not think she
would
be an excellent omb director and
he nominated her because she is
qualified uh because she is somebody who
has a
proven experience and record as i
outlined earlier of
working with different groups and
organizations with different political
beliefs
and because he believes that her own
experience will contribute
to taking a fresh perspective and a
fresh approach to this position
uh so we simply just disagree with uh
whether she's the right person for the
job with
these senators so president biden did
not have any concerns about her past
statements
i i think i'll i'll leave it at what
i've said so far go ahead one more time
more housekeeping by this time in their
presidencies both
donald president trump and president
obama had held solo press conferences so
are there plans for president biden
to hold a solo press conference anytime
soon he will hold a solo press
conference but i don't have a date for
you at this point
this week not this week no go ahead
he inquisitors himself what did you say
will he get to pick the inquisitors
himself
well well typically any president has a
list of people that
they're going to call upon but usually
it's a large number of people who are in
the press room and we certainly hope
we'll be able to do that in a covenant
safe way go ahead
thanks jen a couple if i could i'm one
just following up on mira tandon
um has the white house reached out to
any republicans who have not yet said
how they're going to vote
we have been working the phones in touch
with uh democrats and republicans and
their offices through the course of the
weekend
bill a cbo analysis uh suggested that
only
a small portion of the 130 billion for
schools
would actually be spent in the current
fiscal year
what exactly is the white house doing to
ensure that money would actually mean
that schools could potentially open in
march and april
before the academic year ends well a big
part of the challenge here for a number
of schools is that
they need in order to operate
responsibly and given the threat of
budget cuts they need to obligate funds
according to spending plans rather than
exhausting all balances as soon as
they're received so the challenge here
is
how do they plan ahead right they can
hire if they need to hire additional
teachers now
for smaller class sizes or if they need
to hire bus drivers or if they need to
hire
they need to do um improvements to their
facilities
uh they want to be able to know uh
understandably just like any business or
company that they will be able to employ
teachers next year in the year ahead
so uh that's why this funding is so
essential is because they need to be
able to plan ahead so that they can make
the improvements now do the hiring now
uh go ahead thanks jen um just quickly
on iran has there been any progress
in learning whether iran is going to
come to the table
and sit down i mean any word privately
back channels
uh any progress where it really stands
right now is the europeans issued the
invitation
and they're waiting for a response from
the iranians so i don't have anything
more to read out beyond that
just build on what caitlyn was saying i
mean the president uh he said that there
was going to be a new tone in washington
uh obviously mansion collins do not feel
that this is a new tone so how does the
president kind of square
that saying that he does want a new tone
we're going to have
a new language new no respect
for everyone and this you know fire on
the spot kind of policy you said
have you asked senator manchin and
senator collins about whether they think
uh president biden has a new tone well i
mean i think senator manchin and senator
claus have said that
they have concerns about uh about her
tweets and her language
and we we disagree on whether she is the
right choice for
omb to lead the omb uh but that
is a bit of an overstatement to suggest
that anyone and you should ask them and
unless you've had interviews with them
then please speak up and convey that to
us but
uh they they both have had regular
conversations with president biden
we look forward to finish we look
forward to working with them
on a range of priorities and issues
whether it's the american rescue plan
whether it is immigration addressing the
outdated
immigration system whether it is foreign
policy issues and
he'll continue to engage and have
discussions with a range of senators
including people where he
has disagreements i think the question
is does the pres
is the president okay with the language
and rhetoric that near tandem has used
in direction of other members of
congress including some democrats
and especially republicans i think the
fact that the president nominated her
to lead the budget to be running omb
reflects uh his view that she's the
right person to be in his cabinet
to uh lead the be overseeing the budget
uh and that her qualifications uh her
history of uh working across the aisle
with
people from different groups uh who have
different points of view
is a reflection of how she would uh do
that role
can i ask you about um some members of
malcolm x's family have made public
that a letter that they said was written
by a deceased police officer
that stated that a new york police
department and fbi
may have been behind the 1965 killing
of the activist i just wanted to know
does the administration think that this
is something that should be looked into
i have not seen that letter if you're
if you want to provide it to us i'm
happy to have the right person look into
it after the briefing
sure saudi arabia thank you so much um
you know president obama
you've noted that he does not plan to
speak with around prince
um but i wanted to ask what does that
actually mean
i mean the president has obviously
called for accountability for the murder
of journalist
jamal khashoggi uh but how is the
relationship
actually going to change i mean is this
just symbolism
do are we going to have some concrete uh
changes
that should demonstrate this
accountability well what i conveyed last
week when we talked about this a little
bit is that we are certainly
recalibrating our relationship with
saudi arabia part of what i mentioned
was uh that we will have officials
communicate from counterpart to
counterpart and
uh that means as as you may know last
week the secretary of defense uh
had a conversation with uh with mbs and
that is the right counterpart to
counterpart we expect the president will
have a conversation
uh with the king at an appropriate time
uh but there are other components as you
know of our relationship
including the fact that the president
unlike the last administration is not
going to hold back and speaking out when
he has
objections concerns about issues related
to human rights freedom of speech
any other concerns he may have about the
way things are being run
at the same time there's an important uh
role we can play in relationship as it
relates to
the threats that come into the kingdom
of saudi arabia from
actors in the region and that is a
relationship that we will continue to
work with them on uh go ahead uh
my presence participate in the memorial
victims
is there any discussion about a more
permanent memorial uh something that
would kind of honor their memory
you know long term it's a great question
i don't have anything to report out for
you
um but i'm happy to check with our team
and see if that's under consideration
as you noted i mean tonight obviously he
is uh
he uh and his uh and the vice president
they will be commemorating of
the lives lost the many hundreds of
thousands of families who have been
impacted
by uh the lives that have been lost from
the pandemic
something he also did just a month ago
around the inauguration
and so clearly and and these remarks i
would uh i would convey are not
it's not he will not be providing an
update on progress this is to
uh really have uh a human moment um and
a moment to remember the people
uh who have lost over the last year but
i'm happy to talk to our team if there's
anything like that under consideration
uh previously you mentioned that there
were concerns about how difficult it is
to get a vaccine shot
you know it's hard to sign up for these
things and that the government is
looking into making this easier you know
the white house the federal government
is looking into this what progress is
made on that uh
what is under consideration for how the
federal government could step in
in this situation well we've taken a
number of steps including
working to open several community health
centers um that are in people's local
communities and
people the health and medical experts
who are working at these health centers
often know the people in their
communities and they're trusted by the
people in their communities
we also have been working um with
pharmacies and have several
dozen pharmacy partners across the
country more than 90 percent of the
people in the country and people living
in this country i should say live within
five miles of a pharmacy
that is helps helps many it doesn't help
everybody but that's another
place we've also worked to help launch
some
mass vaccination sites uh to ensure that
people can go with their families and
get vaccinated uh in these locations
so you know we are on track uh we have
we have vaccinated we have we have
significantly expedited the
rate of vaccination over the past couple
of weeks we're at about
in the last week or so we're at about
1.7 million a day or last two weeks or
so 1.7 million a day
prior to the president taking office it
was more around 800
to 900 000 uh but there's work that
needs to continue
and uh that includes ensuring we have
the vaccinations and
ensuring we have the vaccinators needed
to do those vaccinations and the sites
as i touched on across the country who
can
uh facilitate that concern
the websites the phone calls how hard it
is actually booked the employment not
the actual place to go to
well the place to go to is a huge factor
in that because
a community well but this is something
we've done a lot of work and research on
a community health center
that's located in the middle of a
community where people know to go to for
basic health care
for uh you know child for questions
about their kids for pediatric
appointments
that's a place that's trusted in their
community so it's important that
those are places that are open now in a
range of communities across the country
uh pharmacies which are actually the
places where you can do exactly what you
just said
and log on online and make an
appointment
to get a vaccine we've just doubled the
number of
uh vaccines that are going to those
pharmacies we made an announcement last
week
so there are a number of steps that
we're taking to ensure that more
vaccines are getting out the door and
they're getting into communities
go ahead in the back thank you i have
two brief
foreign policy questions the president
has an
excellent relationship with pope francis
who also has had considerable outreach
with iran
he greeted president rouhani he's been
in touch with the ayatollahs
could he be a possible back channel or
is he already
a possible back channel on iran
you're correct he does and there's a
certainly a picture on his desk
uh or in his in the oval office that is
a reflection of that
um but uh the proper channels at this
point are
uh we're gonna work in partnership and
through the p5 plus one
uh partners and allies we've we worked
through for the first rounds of the
uh putting the jcpoa together we're
waiting at this point
to hear back the europeans are waiting
to hear back from the iranians and
whether they
are open to that diplomatic conversation
so uh
really the the discussions are at that
stage at this point so the pope's not
going to be
involved in any way in that i i
certainly would never claim to speak for
pope francis for pope francis or any
pope um and
uh you can certainly reach out to the
vatican if they have intention of
getting engaged in some capacity
the other question i have is that
as vice president the president met
and talked to the president
of rwanda paul kagame does he have any
views on the current trial that's going
on
in rwanda of paul russell
the central figure in the hotel rwanda
movie
uh who many say was kidnapped illegally
but who the government defends and said
should be on trial
uh it's a great question i have not
spoken with our national security team
about
uh the particular trial i'm happy to
talk to them and we can follow up with
you after the briefing
happy too absolutely go ahead one more
on the airplane
of the night you said she's only met
with
35 senators is that correct is there oh
over at least 35 had over 35 meetings
there a reason she's not met with more
has any gop
senator refused to meet with her i i
don't think we're going to speak to as
we would in any case
um who she's met to or give you get met
with or give you a list of to protect
the privacy of senators but
uh 35 meetings with republican and
democratic senators is actually quite a
significant number of
meetings in the process but okay can we
take him but if you look at how
controversial her nomination is in the
context of your
broader legislative agenda and other
legislative items that will face an
uphill battle in congress do you risk
uh do you risk political capital by
forging ahead with this or do you see it
completely unrelated
look i think uh the president nominated
nero tandon because she
he felt she was the right person to lead
the budget office um
because she has uh decades of experience
uh because she would bring fresh
perspective to the job
uh because uh she has a record of
working with uh people from a range of
organizations of different viewpoints
uh but uh you know and we're gonna we
remain committed to
moving that process forward to a
confirmation but there are arranged
even areas where we disagree we may have
disagreement of course with senator
manchin or
senator collins about whether she's the
right person to lead but we are still
going to work with them
on a range of other issues that are of
mutual interest
and of interest to the american people
and that includes the rescue plan
that includes uh you know many
components of the president's agenda
moving forward
oh so let's try one more go ahead
one other one semiconductor shortage
asked about
two weeks ago or a week ago now uh brian
these and jake sullivan i think are
working on this and
um you could there was outreach to the
chinese and other countries
any update on responses that you got
from these countries on how to
fix it and i know you guys also
acknowledge that there is no
fix but something in the medium term
since it is
really impacting a lot of businesses
absolutely and there's been outreach to
the manufacturing sector and companies
as well to discuss the impact of the
shortage you mentioned
the letter uh that was reported that uh
brian diese our nec director sent
uh to taiwan there has been a lot of
outreach to
international partners as well as we
work through this issue
uh but i expect we'll have more in the
coming days to share with you on the
next steps here
go ahead hey jen thanks two questions
the first is on texas
some folks have come home to
astronomical electric bills
uh and there are you know stories about
those being the result of deregulation
uh and other issues being the result of
life regulation i wonder if the
president plans to weigh in on that or
talk to that does he
still plan to go to texas or does he
kind of go to texas
sure well the president is eager to go
to texas i traveled with him on mission
on michigan to michigan i should say uh
on friday and he was
closely tracking uh of course the the
work that fema was underway he spoke
with his acting administrator
on the way back from that trip he has
been getting updates from his national
security team over the course of the
weekend
and he wants to go and show his support
he also
is fully aware of the footprint
of a president of the united states and
everything that comes with that
traveling to a disaster area but we are
hopeful
uh that that trip can happen as early as
this week one more question on the
hopefully getting a preview of the
timber of tonight's speech um
i wonder if there is a worry from the
white house that giving positive news on
the corona virus front
that people will let down their guards
as has happened in the past and
numbers will go up or spike again does
the president plan to address any of
that tonight or is it just reflecting on
mid-range
you know the president uh felt it was
important on a personal level and human
level to
uh mark the lives lost over the past
year
uh nearly a year of this pandemic and
that's the purpose of
tonight both the remarks he'll be
delivering but also the moment of
silence
uh that we will all be participating in
uh from wherever you are located
um but you know he is also quite mindful
so
the tonight is not the night to to
give advice to the public or give an
update on progress being made
but he has at every opportunity he has
been given
from last friday to most times he's
speaking publicly
convey that uh his focus and his
commitment is on
getting the american rescue plan passed
ensuring we have enough vaccines to
vaccinate 300 million americans
but the american people have a role to
play here as well which is
wearing masks social distancing
everybody wants to get back to normal
but the president the federal government
can't do that alone
it is going to take everybody
participating in that process to
uh to get closer to normalcy in the
country
go in the back thank you jen i have one
question on
one from canadian journalist
this is follow-up on nordstrom 2.
several republican members of congress
criticized the administration for a
failure
to name new targets for
sanctions related to north stream 2
in a report required by congress and
democratic senator
jin shaking is also asking for
uh explanation and just today foreign
ministers of poland and
ukraine urged president trump
president biden to stop the project
your response well president biden's
view
remains that nordstrom 2 is a bad deal
it's a bad deal because it divides
europe it exposes ukraine
and central europe to russian
manipulation and because it goes against
europe's own stated energy and security
goals which i think is a shared concern
that many of the individuals you
mentioned
have expressed we're continuing to
monitor activity
to um to complete or to certify uh the
pipeline and if such activity takes
place
we'll make a determination on the
applicability of sanctions
and sanctions are only one of many
important tools to ensure energy
security so we're also
going to work with our allies and
partners to reinforce
european energy security and to
safeguard against the sort of predatory
behavior we have warned against
this is a question from james mccarten
from the canadian press
ahead of president biden's meeting with
prime minister justin trudeau so he's
asking
what commitments is the president
prepared to make to prime minister
regarding the continued
detention of two canadians in china
and is the president biden willing to
make
exceptions from his by american
provisions
for canadian contractors and suppliers
well on the second one um you know he
signed an executive order
uh we're of course evaluating
procurement
components of that but no changes
anticipated of course the prime minister
will bring up whatever he would like to
bring up as is true of any bilateral
meeting
we expect the president during the
meeting to highlight
the strong and deep partnership between
the united states and canada as
neighbors friends and nato allies
that they will discuss issues of mutual
interest from kovid 19
to climate change and the economic ties
that bind our countries as well as the
deep people
people bonds we share and after the
conclusion of the meeting i'm sure we'll
have a readout of
what was discussed and communicated
during
uh or his first bilateral meeting
go ahead um thanks jim even while
acknowledging the grim milestone that
we're hitting today and 500 000 deaths
in the country
it's worth mentioning that around the
country cases
hospitalizations and deaths currently
are plummeting
um and as the pace of vaccine uh
vaccination
increases i'm wondering does the
administration think that we're either
at or close to a sort of turning point
as it comes to the pandemic
well i certainly understand the question
and it's one that i'm sure all of your
friends and neighbors are asking you
as well um but i i know there'll be a
briefing later this afternoon with our
health experts as we do monday wednesday
and friday
um you know i would say though that 500
000
a milestone of 500 000 deaths is
certainly not something we're
celebrating and it's hardly something
it's something to commemorate and to
take a moment to remember
all of the families that have been
impacted across the country
we feel there has been some progress
made we're leading the world of the
number of vaccine
vaccinations administered and second
only to israel
in the share of population fully
vaccinated
we're of course implementing new masking
requirements to make sure people stay
safe but as someone alluded to or an
earlier question we need to remain
vigilant
both from the federal government uh the
american people need to
um you know and uh it's still going to
be months and months
of sacrifice uh of work
of of suffering unfortunately in order
to get through the pandemic
thanks everyone
you